pascal mende et 44 ans
élue déléguée à l'éducation populaire la
jeunesse et prévention délinquance sur
la commune de san luis et
aujourd'hui président de commission la
cohésion et solidarité sociale au
département
alors élu du canton 15 200 lui est
l'attachement que j'ai aujourd'hui sur
ce canton c'est que je suis né à
saint-louis 44 auquel et j'y vis j'y
habite je côtoie et on ne peut pas
laisser en aparté 7 ce canton là parce
que quand vous vivez dans un canton où
vous grandissez vous connaissez les gens
vous pouvez que vous y attachez par
amour et par affection et surtout qu'on
sonne authenticité
les changements qu'on devrait s'atteler
vraiment se poser la question sur notre
canton sur tout le canton 15 le canton
16 de sa vie c'est arrivé à créer
justement ce lien avec la parole et à la
parentalité la parentalité pour que
justement puisse avoir ce lien avec les
familles et apporter une solution
adéquate et adaptée au besoin par
rapport à ces deux cantons là et je
pense aussi que sur la réunion je pense
qu'on a le même problème les familles
aujourd'hui ont besoin d'un soutien et
surtout d'une visibilité une
transparence de ce que le département
puisse leur apporter qu'ils soient dans
la parentalité au niveau de l'enfance au
niveau des personnes âgées les personnes
handicapées apporter une accessibilité
plus facile une simplicité au sidaction
le département aujourd'hui comme tout le
monde le sait c'est vraiment le fils
social fil conducteur de la vie
réunionnaise est aussi cet apport au
niveau des familles qui sont dans le
besoin moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui
département devrait avoir des élus le
plus proche de la population des élus de
proximité qui font un travail de terrain
pour apporter des solutions aux besoins
mais pour connaître les besoins il faut
connaître aussi quels sont ces familles
qui sont dans ses besoins sur le
territoire